every single November he is the voice of
my discontent he is Joel clot getting
septic all Ohio State at Michigan how
are you Joel
oh man I'm it's so I mean it's so sad to
hear that I my voice just brings a
depressing aura over you well you know
what it's not my it's not like I know
it's not like Oprah and Kramer where I
just go into all sorts of shock just
hearing a voice but look hey you called
Michigan Michigan State and that worked
out pretty darn well for me so maybe
maybe we've turned a corner here but
let's talk reality and X's and O's
because the Ohio State comes in with
chase Young and Justin fields and
Dobbins and Olave and they come in as
the number one overall team in the
college football playoff do you think
let's start with that is that's a proper
ranking for Ohio State Joe I do think
it's a proper ranking i when you look at
their overall body of work their ability
to dominate rich they're number one in
scoring offense and defense in the
country they've also got the number one
point differential they have the three
ranked wins that is exactly like LSU and
while LSU has a better road lens
certainly and you would say their resume
might be a little bit better they have a
clear what I would call weakness which
is their defense which is in the 40s
when you're talking about scoring and
total defense so I thought it was a
proper ranking I really did night I
think this committee of the the versions
of committees that we've had over the
years I think this one is is the best
that I've seen you can have being sit I
think it's gonna be really interesting
you're moving forward so moving forward
obviously this game that you're calling
with Gus can affect so much in the
rankings and so much obviously for the
Big Ten and getting a team into the
college football playoff so let's let's
start breaking this down chase young you
kept commenting over and over again how
Penn State blocked him and single with
just
one guy there were no chips there is no
help very rarely if at all do you think
Michigan is going to take the same
approach Joe no I don't think so I think
I think Jim Harbaugh is far too
sophisticated with his history in this
game I think Josh Gattis is too smart
for that
I think you're gonna see a combination
of two things one you're gonna see the
line slide towards chase young with a
chip and you're also going to see the
ball out quickly that's one of the
reasons why they went to this offense
richness speed in space offense with
Josh Gattis is the first time play
caller and offensive coordinator was to
try to throw the football and control
the game with the short passing game so
they didn't have to just sit there and
be bullies and run the ball out of big
sets like they have in previous years
chases I got to tell you and I can't
wait to talk about this in Vegas when we
all get there for the draft right he's
as good as I've seen man I gotta tell
you I and I saw in Dom kansui and
covered in dominant super Dom kansui is
not nearly as productive or dominant of
a player as chase young is he he's got
this combination of like of Barry Bonds
and a guy like like Lawrence Taylor you
know and in the sense that every time
you felt like the Giants needed a big
play if there was a big play to be made
in a game third down they need someone
to put pressure on the quarterback
Taylor was there right he was there and
then he's like bonds in the sense rich
that Barry when he hit 73 home runs you
know he also set the record that year
for single-season walks he would get
like two strikes a week and he would hit
him both out of the park right so chase
when he gets one-on-one he like he gets
a set it's just it's clock when I'm
sitting up in the booth and I see these
formations play out and I'm like oh yeah
I mean here he comes
this is gonna be a sack and it's like
bonds getting a fastball on a 200 count
on a random Tuesday in July he's gonna
hit it out of the park and then I don't
and then I remember watching
I remember watching Wisconsin attempt
- just let him come in and throw over
him for a screen or a quick play and he
was too quick for even that I mean you
don't need to know you don't need to
identify him yeah I know you've got that
ability to hit hit a button or use a
stylo or whatever it is a stylus and and
identify him through a graphic you don't
need we know where he is I mean he jumps
off the screen Joel I know I mean I even
made a failed comic book reference I
don't know if you caught that it's at
the nerds and the nerdery were very
upset with me because what happened I
said he was Superman and the rest of the
defense was the Avengers like Superman
and the Avengers and everyone's like pop
those comic book heroes don't fight
together I'm like I first of all I
didn't know that second of all if you're
really upset that's your problem and
third of all now it's a thing so I will
say before the minute mark of the first
quarter Superman and the Avengers again
this week on national television 2:15 go
for I guess I guess that's your
kryptonite if you will that you don't
know that those facts off the top of
your head man you know in a way
obviously this game a joke lot here on
the Richard show this game is brought to
you by the number two chase young where
is it Dobbins where is it so does Shea
Patterson the Michigan offense is
remarkably clicking just like Jim
Harbaugh said at halftime of that Penn
State loss that our finest hours about
to hit and he is correct how does this
offense match up with the rest of I
guess the Avengers if you will for for
the Ohio State Joe listen I appreciate
you running with this with me I think it
actually matches up really well there's
a couple of things that that I think
Ohio State does better than anybody on
defense one is obviously rush the passer
we just talked about that the other is
that they have this ability to put three
corners on the field
Sean Wayne wait excuse me Jeff Okuda and
Damon Arnett who by the way all might be
first you know early second-round pick
soku to probably go in the top ten
they're really remarkable cover players
and so they can take away
a lot of what you do in the past game
but the problem is is that they're not
overly tall and Michigan has these three
four guys that they can put out there a
wide receiver that are a matchup
nightmare and so they're gonna force
Ohio State to spread out and that's not
necessarily what I'll how state wants to
do which is walk those linebackers out a
guy like Pete Warner number 20 watch out
for him they run a very NFL style of
defense that the single high safety was
name's Jordan fuller number four it
looks a lot like the Seahawks this is a
very sea hawk Legion of Doom
boom excuse me type of type of deal and
yet Michigan has at least in my
estimation the type of personnel that
can threaten them because they can they
can spread everything out try to run the
football that way slow down the pass
rush they've been doing that with Hassan
Haskins and Zack Charbonnet and then
ultimately try to control the game with
the short passing game and if they can
do that they'll neutralize the rush of
chase young and then they can
potentially get those DBS frustrated and
maybe allow for a shot later with those
tall wide receivers well in last year's
game the offense was thoroughly
inefficient kept getting three and outed
putting its defense back out there and
Don Browns defense got sliced up
crossing and routed to death and and you
know and the guy who came up with that
game plan is now the the head coach with
Justin fields at the top of his game and
a Heisman groove how how will it be
different this time or might it not when
Justin fields gets out against the
Michigan defense this time about Joel
well Justin does not throw the ball
nearly as well as Dwayne Haskins does
and and I would argue if you're a
Michigan fan if you're if you're you
rich right I would argue that that it
wasn't necessarily Ryan day or that
killed you over the last couple of years
or necessarily the game plan I could
make a really strong argument that Don
Browns kryptonite was actually Dewayne
Haskins okay if you go all the way back
to 2016 when Don Brown came to Michigan
he was giving up just over a point a
drop
okay point per possession to Ohio State
when JT Barrett was the quarterback they
lost in overtime then they had the lead
in 2017 late into the third quarter and
I thought it was over when the backup
payment yes yes and and then the kids
from Maryland jogs out on the field did
you know from that point until the end
of the game in 2018 Dewayne Haskins was
averaging over four points a possession
with Ohio State against Don Brown so you
could make a strong argument that it was
the passing ability to pocket presence
the ability to distribute the ball from
the pocket that Dwayne Haskins had that
was actually what killed Michigan and
now you're going back to what I would
deem is more of a JT Barrett style of
offense with Justin fields I think he
throws it a little bit better than JT
Barrett but Michigan has changed their
defensive structure I would say fairly
drastically one of the things that
you'll see in primary passing downs if
you get in a second and long third and
long here's what you'll see from
Michigan for defensive ends on the field
as the defensive linemen they'll have
one linebacker and then they'll have six
DBS
they run what's called bracket coverage
okay so bracket coverage eats up all the
crossing routes so they have strain they
have changed structurally specifically
for Ohio State and rot in day and I
can't wait to see it all play out and I
think the one thing that you got to
beware of weary of if you're a Michigan
fan is Justin fields ability to run the
football
because that's I think the great
equalizer and he showed that last week I
guess what Michigan needed to do was
have Dwayne Haskins take a selfie with a
fan Joel that would that have been the
way to keep him off the field I have no
idea that that was there's a possibility
a man by the way let's revisit last time
you were on the show you dropped that
nugget that based on your knowledge and
your your conversations that the
Washington Redskins coaching staff and
the front office was split over Dwayne
Haskins you received a ton of heat about
that and sure enough Jay
and the Redskins parted ways within
about ten days so I give you kudos for
your information Joel on that yeah I try
not to just throw things out willy-nilly
you know what I appreciate you again you
coming on here and in saying all that so
last one for you there are other games
you've got LSU Texas a.m. Oklahoma
Oklahoma State and the Iron Bowl give me
the spot where you think the result
might be surprising most I think
Oklahoma State has a great chance a
great chance against oh you OU's defense
I struggled and the back half of the
season even though they've made some
critical plays in these last four games
that they've played all one position
possession games the one thing I think
that they struggle with his tact
tackling in particular really agile
athletic players and Shuba hovers the
nation's leading rusher he's a he's a
sensational player for Oklahoma State
and even though they've got a backup
quarterback Andrew Brown that's going to
start for them I think Oklahoma State
has a real good chance in that game
against owe you and keep in mind
oh you has been sneaking by the last
four games they've won all of those four
in one possession fashion and Jalen
Hertz has had to take more and more
responsibility of the run game in fact
he set season highs and attempts from
the quarterback positions and rushes in
every one of those four games he went 19
rushes and 22 rushes at 27 rushes and
last week 28 times he toted the rock so
I'm a bit concerned with Jalen Hertz and
his workload over the last four and
Shuba Hubbard is quite the player so so
watch out in that fed lump game well
I'll tell you what wouldn't it be
remarkable if it comes down to choosing
one loss Alabama or one loss Jalen hurts
to make the final spot in the college
football semi-final I mean that would be
incredible I mean that's possible unless
they both miss right you know if they
both miss they're gonna play each other
in the Sugar Bowl
that would be amazing wouldn't it if
they both miss yeah but both could hit
if the maize and blue take care of
business on Saturday that could be
possible
little client I love it forever a fan at
heart alright I won't even ask you what
you think's gonna happen you're not you
know who you thinks gonna win all right
I'll do it
what do you got for me what do you think
is gonna happen all right man just be
gentle as all I says all I all I request
just be gentle okay Joel I will tell you
this I will tell you this mhm if
Michigan pulls it off Gus is going
though the whole press box is gonna blow
up Gus is gonna lose his mind well I
mean he does he does from the great
state of Michigan so I I know I know
he's got a little bit of I'm not saying
bias but he's just from the state I mean
that that that just goes without saying
but he's also man you guys are great
listen you really are you have to send
him send him back that way for this
draftees and it's gonna be an
interesting draft yeah you know what
let's do this Joel when when when
everybody when we know what the college
football playoffs looks like let's get
you back on here and we'll start looking
over the steering wheel because by that
point we'll know who won the Heisman and
maybe a little bit better if two is
gonna be in this mix and chase young and
so on and so forth let's have that
conversation safe journey
right back at you that's Joel clot he
and Gus Johnson and the rest of the Fox
college football crew will be in the big
house Saturday for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel - 39
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app